- Les Philippines connaissent
fulgurantes de nouveaux
cas de VIH sur la planète.
Le pays a enregistré
21 000 nouvelles infections
du double qu'en 2015.
Il existe pourtant
un médicament efficace
pour contrer la progression
pré-exposition ou la PrEP.
"La pilule consiste
à prendre quotidiennement
avant une relation sexuelle",
explique la directrice adjointe
du Desmond Tutu HIue du Sud ue e
présidente de la Conférence
internationale sur le sida.
Il a été démontré partout
les individus advenant
qu'ils soient exposés au VIH.
de la population mondiale à
risque a accès au médicament.
Mis en marché en 2010,s,s,s,s,s,
en Afrique du Sud et au Kenya
où les programmes de santé
publique l'ont déployé
Aux Philippines, grâce
à un programme financé
par des fonds privés,nnesnnesnns
reçoivent gratuitement
le médicament. C'est bien
loin des 100 000 personnesénéfi.
"Cette épidémie c ne rendons
pas la PrEP accessible à tous",
explique ce directeur philippin
d'un programme de prévention.
du médicament, la difficulté
d'accès aux cliniques
et la stigmatisationà peineà pee
2000 des 20 000 Népalais
jugés à risque utilisent
la prophylaxie pré-exposition.
que de nombreux utilisateurs
de drogues injectables
aimeraient prendre de la PrEP,
mais elle coûte trop cher",exple
de la santé.
- We cannot treat our way
out of this epidemic...
est aussi essentielle, selon
nseillère du ministère
de la Santé de l'Afrique du Sud.
"Les travailleurscommunautairei
faire de la sensibilisation
pour la PrEP", dit-elle.
On complion
d'utilisateurs de PrEP à travers
le monde, et l'objectif est
à 10 millions d'ici 2025.
dant la crdant la crdant la crdn
d'un vaccin ou d'une cure contre
le VIH, la PrEP est considéréeis
pour freiner cette pandémie.
érie-Micaela Bain,
Radio-Canada, Mon